hello good morning I'm yes this is again
the outfit that we are wearing and my
face is covered in chemo rash but I
think this camera puts an auto filter
when it records so don't mind that don't
hate that feature and also don't know
how to change it fun thing about these
glasses is you can take them off to make
a point big day today it is the day
before Thanksgiving so Elliot and I
obviously thought this would be the best
time for us to go to Costco for the
first time I bought us a Costco card
back in August when I was starting chemo
thinking maybe buying in bulk during
this K process will be the key to
success and we never went have a
membership card sitting in my email that
has not been completely activated and so
we decided why not go the day before
Thanksgiving I don't know if that means
that we're adventurous or if we're
masochists I don't know we're going to
find out I don't know that I've also
ever been to a Costco as an adult we
used to go to Sam's Club a lot growing
up and that always felt like ooh hot
dogs that's all I remember hot dogs I
don't even know exactly why we're go oh
because we have all of our ingredients
to make a bunch of for ourselves
for Thanksgiving but it's all sides we
haven't committed to a protein yet
because neither of us feel very
confident in that realm so we were going
to go to Costco thinking that that place
would have a solution that's some kind
of math works for us so we're going to
try and now Elliott's almost ready to go
to Costco and I got to I want to I got
to clean myself up I got to look
presentable this is a club after all wow
wow wow wow wow what a
confusing
mix of
items
okay what you got oh let's add shrimp
we're back from Costco that was insane
but successful there was a lot of panic
SHO I was over stimulated visually in
just about every direction 360° these
claws were just grabbing things we got
half a ham and we got a tiasu that's
like the size of a baseball bat did I
mention yeah we're just doing
Thanksgiving by ourselves so we are
doing it up and I have a Costco card now
I feel like that has really graduated me
into a class of adult that um I was just
looking at from way down below before
also that store makes me feel like a
little tiny person everything's so big a
store full of Supermarket Sweep bonus
prizes speaking of cute things look at
this how freaking cute is this little
ornament pillow that I got from Target
tell me you're going to look at that and
not feel a little little squeak of Joy a
little tinge of Joy secondly I've gotten
into tea I'm a tea girl now I'm into tea
now okay one of the craziest things
that's happened as a byproduct of having
breast cancer I haven't been drinking
coffee which in hindsight is pretty
crazy I drank before this like easily
three cups of coffee every morning and
then I stopped drinking it so Not only
was I doing chemo recovery rounds I was
also going through coffee withdrawal
which is not like a little thing
especially for someone that was really
jolting themselves full of caffeine
which maybe caused the breast cancer in
the first place who knows I don't you
know there's many things that I put in
my body and done with my body that could
have caused this breast cancer so I'll
just never know but I'll know that it's
probably something I did and now I'm
getting into teas and seasonal teas oh
God this is a spiced apple cinnamon tea
and damn I am really
becoming the PG version of myself I
thought maybe my personality was like a
p PG-13 light and now I'm just
PG there was something else that I
turned this camera on to say oh right I
officially have a surgery scheduled for
mid December that's the next month never
updated you after the calcium deposit
biopsy calcium deposits the sample they
had came back like basically benign but
also atypical so my surgical doctor is
still a little concerned about them and
I am opting for a lumpectomy surgery and
with that my surgical doctor will be
going going in to get a surgical sample
of these calcium deposits so a bigger
sample than they could get with the
biopsy so we can know for for for for
for sure if they show any signs of risk
or not so I'll be in recovery basically
over the holidays which I'm so fine with
because I'm it just means that I'm
moving along this path and then I think
after surgery I'll go into radiation all
of those details are getting worked out
right now so that's the update but
before that Thanksgiving Happy
Thanksgiving it has begun it's happening
it's happening we're cooking your weird
aunt and your professor uncle are
cooking have stuffing started with
sausage happening and sweet potato
something is in there it's exciting C
sweet potato cass sweet po casserole
eggs sted eggs are going to go in there
it's as exciting as it is chaotic hello
a we're going to eat until we explode
okay the devil eggs have suffered okay
us he's a frying some chicken dogs are
being dogs over there this other show
dog is being quite a show dog all kinds
of stuff in the oven right now and oh my
God and that's ham that's stuffing and I
cut my finger almost immediately well we
did it we made
um quite a Fe
look at this my goodness your kingdom
awaits and it's all edible so have a lot
to do busy busy we have put a
Dent into this tiasu log oh hello that's
the Eagles game this is Grace Sunday
night I was journaling watching the
Eagles we just got back a couple hours
ago from going to see Napoleon a lot of
masculine energy today on this full moon
which is an expression of the feminine
we just been doing some light journaling
about that kind of she's there
there's another football game on that TV
I don't know who put that on I'm not
watching that right now maybe goose is
clearly that's the update Sunday Funday
journaling about my feelings and uh
watching go Birds good morning 5:37 a.m.
it is the morning of my final round of
chemo obviously I couldn't sleep
Elliot's still sleeping so that's why
we're Whispering cuz we're respectful
and I thought I'd make myself breakfast
because I I just got someone told me
about all the flavors of Kodiak brand of
pancake mix and so I bought them we got
birthday cake blueberry and pumpkin I
think I'm going to make some birthday
cake pancakes this morning because today
is a celebration that's awesome that's a
nice way to start the day I haven't
vlogged a lot the last couple days
because I've just been feeling like
weirdly down I think I'm going to try to
explain it later today if I have energy
and I've talked to Elliot and my
therapist and my friends I'm a family
and on the podcast a little bit about
this but I haven't talked specifically
here but this is like the most exciting
last week final week of chemo like once
I walk out of that building I don't go
back well I go back from infusions
tomorrow but then after I walk out that
day I don't really go back for anything
that I know of but I also haven't known
a lot through this process so who knows
metaphorically I don't go back that's so
exciting so proud and relieved all the
good feelings but also this week I just
felt like like nervous down displaced
and a little dissociated strange was
expecting I guess to feel more energized
and excited but definitely like oh
there's like a Melancholy that's been
lingering I don't know if it's
depression or if it's just kind of the
overwhelm of moving from one phase of
this treatment process that was familiar
or had become familiar you know how to
do all of it now I understand like The
rhythms of my body and the recovery
period and now that'll be done and we to
another phase of surgery that is
unfamiliar so that changes like I think
made me feel a little stressed also like
that this part is going to be over that
we've gotten so familiar with it that
it's like a graduation what better way
to celebrate than with some birthday
pancakes let's do it the mix has
sprinkles in it that's so cute there you
go they are um I would not use beautiful
as an adjective to describe them yeah
they are beautiful actually they're
beautiful and I make myself ail lattes
now because I'm a big cool girl and then
I like to pull a card from the wild
unknown archetype stick on the morning
said I do my chemo treatments I haven't
been having time to do it for the last
one or two just fun just fun for me what
a strange day that's what the energy is
this whole thing is weird and not in
like a bad
derogatory um way just weird so strange
so strange but look at that Christmas
treat this is today's fit another
appropriate and adorable t-shirt killer
shoes round
six ice packs
first go time here with our
girls okay
infusions are officially done and we're
just waiting for the cold cap to cool
down
yeah very exciting
business we're getting out of here cuz
I'm
finished we're home we finished chemo
round six which finishes chemo I have so
many feelings about today that I don't
even know what I'm feeling I am tired
but wow incredible got in the car after
and just cried for a while so I'm
emotion Ally drained I'm physically
drained and wow I'm going to continue to
process this it's just really
unbelievable the whole thing is weird
and unbelievable but I'm very grateful
for the support system I have for you
guys following along and being so
supportive just so many amazing messages
I don't know if one person is meant to
process that much um like parasocial
support it's incredible thank you and
just like my family and my friends being
so loving and so sweet and Elliot
especially Elliot my God glad I married
that dude I'm going to rest wow
incredible I don't really know what to
say about classically one last time
we're in hydration yeah it's a thrill
it's just a damn thrill it's the last
one so many Ms I am home from hydration
the official cycle of everything I need
to get in my body for round six that
happens outside of my house is done
sorry if you hear my laundry going I am
washing my bed sheets because I am doing
my prehibernation recovery Nest rituals
cleaning my bed sheets vacuuming the
floors what people call General house
tidying La just texted me that the sky
is beautiful right now and it is I can
feel the fatigue kind of starting to
come on now so I wanted to record this
before I got too tired look how the
festivities have spread like good
bacteria going into this week I had a
lot more Melancholy than I expected I
don't know what I expected this whole
thing is very surreal sometimes you feel
so clear about your feelings and
sometimes you just feel like you're in
this emotional limbo and it's just hard
to make sense of what you're feeling and
maybe you're not supposed to make sense
of what you're feeling maybe you're just
supposed to be but I was feeling more
down than I was feeling excited start do
some journaling and I started to just
make a list of reflection of things that
I've learned or things that I have
realized are important I thought maybe I
would share them with you been quite a
vulnerable and intimate Journey thus far
these are cliche and these are a bit
corny and you have definitely heard all
of these in some way shape or form
before but I do think that there's value
in sharing it because sometimes you hear
something you've heard before but the
moment you're hearing it you're just
more open to receive it and hits you
differently it's like continuing to
throw a ball at someone that's not
looking and it bounces off their head
and then one time they turn their body
and they catch it and they throw it back
to you and
now you're playing catch with a stranger
kind of like that first thing reaching
out to someone is so important if you
have a passing thought about sending a
message in any shape or form from like
extremely formal to just a Emoji to
someone do it I can't tell you how
amazing it was to receive throughout
this process just so many different
types of communication from so many
different people in my life from so many
different chapters of my life and I'm a
very private person and I keep to myself
I get a little scared about reaching out
to people sometimes and so to receive
someone thinking about me was like so
meaningful in a process that is at times
extremely isolating as human beings we
all have this desire to be understood
and to be seen whether we're conscious
of it or not and there's a lot of
wanting to hide in this process but to
feel like people were reaching out
because they cared was just so amazing I
don't do that as much as you know I
think I would like to so these are a lot
of like notes to self feeling all of
your feelings is so important you know I
used to make dress to repress merch and
I've gone through the last few years a
huge sort of growth process of really
attempting to understand my feelings I
get very overwhelmed and so I'll just
stuff it down um you can't live like
that you can't live like that it comes
out in other ways to deny your feelings
is to deny your reality and then that
denial just infects you in a negative
way um if it's not direct it's indirect
turns out crying is really good to do I
let it out and it's just nice I've
talked about this before it's like an
emotional burp and it feels so nice to
pass pass that gas advocating for
yourself is so huge very privileged to
have very little experience in the
medical world I've been generally pretty
healthyish I've also been extremely
healthy to have incredible medical
professionals working with me but I have
learned the importance of advocating for
yourself in these very serious
experiences like I wouldn't have
probably gotten my breast cancer
diagnosis if I didn't ask my
gynecologist about this weird Mass lump
thing and it took me a lot to get those
words from my brain out of my mouth to
her and I kept thinking that I was
overreacting my default is that I'm the
problem
hi I'm the problem it's me but I'm not
I'm not the tumor was the problem don't
be afraid to advocate for yourself or
bring someone with you that will
advocate for you do I really need to do
that or what is this and also can you
explain this to me like I'm 8 years old
that's advocating for yourself because a
lot of times I just say uh-huh uh-huh
uh-huh uh-huh and I forget to follow up
that I don't actually know what the this
doctor is saying to me pushing through
what I think makes me look dumb to get
clarity on things that are really
important for me to be alive the Sun is
setting so this will get darker only
lightwise hopefully I've had a lot of
thoughts about how I feel about being
diagnosed at like a young age I I don't
know why younger people have gotten
diagnoses I haven't had a lot of anger
through this process I think on some
level I was so ready for my life to be
shooken up because I had felt so stuck
and stagnant and had started making some
progress of understanding my feelings
but still felt very trapped in like my
own Loops of thoughts and there is a
weird
Blessing about this experience and all
of its own weirdness and that I do feel
like the universe took me by the
shoulders and shook me and was like you
want to wake up call here you go look
down to the left and feel around as
important as it is to not deny the
reality of your situation it is
important to try to find maybe what
gifts are hidden among all the
asking for help is so major wow I guess
I knew that but I hate asking for help
I'll do the group project reluctantly
but I will do it young age I just like
learn to take care of myself and then I
just like did that and that became like
my survival mechanism or a way that like
was successful for me at certain points
in my life so I just inherently grew
this belief system that I can take care
of myself in all areas of life in some
way maybe not to the best of an ability
but I can take care of myself and turns
out I can't cure breast cancer it turns
out too that like people want to help
asking is so important it's so important
in a way you could reframe thinking that
it's actually like a sign of strength to
ask for help because you care about
yourself that much and you know your own
limits self-care would be asking someone
else for care for yourself a lot of
Frameworks are shifting for me right now
I hope no inspectors are coming by
because the foundation of this house is
a little rocky right now don't forget to
nurture your relationships they're like
a living organism that evolves and
shifts as the work and effort gets put
into it from both sides is just really
illuminated for me that I want to be
more involved in the relationships I
have with family and friends and my
husband and my dog and my creative work
and you guys I don't want to just hide
the only way those things continue to
grow is by watering them same for a
fatigued body I told you these were
cliches I told you you've heard these
all before your body does so much and
it's so complex and also amazing nurture
it and give it credit it don't beat it
up you're working together I have a long
history of beating up my body because I
was privileged enough that it could take
it Eating Disorders to binge drinking to
like lack of consistent care it was
interesting to notice that like when I
started to feel really bad in my
recovery periods I'd have this like
immediate thought that like my body was
failing and I'd get upset with it and
then someone would say whether in a
comment or Elliot or a family member on
the phone or something that like how
amazing is your body for doing what it's
doing it is putting up such a fight in
this big ass battle and it would again
shift my framework of being like why am
I getting upset at myself right now
reality is my body is doing more than I
could have asked it to do I need to
befriend my body in this situation I've
had a long history of not being friends
with my body you've been doing a really
great job and I have been not doing a
great job of letting you know that so I
just want you to know that even you left
ITT okay it'll still be a process so
after all of this to learn how to trust
my body again because obviously this
throws you totally out of whack eager to
facilitate that process of like working
with my body and not against it damn 38
you having a cliche midlife crisis it's
okay to not know what you're doing when
I got diagnosed I
thought ah I don't really want this
because I don't know how to do this and
that's okay you figure it out as you go
trust your own capacity to be able to
figure things out as you go um last one
you just never know what anyone is going
through it blew my mind through this
process that I would just like go to
Target to run errands thinking to myself
everyone in the store is just watching
me buy some makeup wipes and some
melatonin but they have no idea that I'm
in the middle of fighting breast cancer
and if I have this invisible medical
baggage that I'm walking around the
world with what could everyone else in
this store possibly possibly have
kindness and compassion for other people
go a long way and I think it's important
to remember that we just do not know
what everyone is going through again to
Circle back why it's important to reach
out to people if you get that urge okay
that's my little list a bit of a long
list pretty cliche but have been more
meaningful and important to me through
this process maybe one or a few of them
connect with you I'm going to let myself
fall into my fatigue and Recovery I
can't believe round six is over over uh
oh not over not over I can't believe
round six has been administered and now
here we go hopefully I'll get this up
before I fall too far into my cocoon but
thank you and again ending these is more
difficult than it has been cuz I just
want to keep talking to you guys no I
got to go I'm tired I need to smoke
marijuana and eat some bland food oh my
God
tgit uh I'll see you next time I pick up
this camera I don't know